[Música]
imagínense que estamos en el año 2030 a
sólo 11 años de ahora
los niños que están en primer grado
estarán entrando a su edad adulta
algunos de los adultos más
experimentados como un roberto estarán
jubilando
y qué tal el resto de nosotros que
estamos y seguiremos en nuestra edad
productiva
ya se han imaginado cómo serán sus
trabajos en 11 años
espero que al pensar en esta pregunta
todos hayan incorporado a la tecnología
en su visión del futuro porque ésta
avanza cada vez más rápidamente y es
absorbida por todas las áreas de
nuestras vidas estamos en lo que hoy se
conoce como la cuarta revolución
industrial
uno de los temas que causa más ansiedad
cuando hablamos de esto es en de la
automatización de actividades y procesos
y el posible desplazamiento de las
personas que actualmente cumplen con
esos trabajos en el 2030 1 de cada 6 de
nosotros podría perder su trabajo a la
automatización esto es lo que nos dice
un estudio de mckinsey que indica que
para este año se podrían perder hasta
800 millones de trabajos alrededor del
mundo a la automatización causada solo
por las tecnologías que ya han sido
probadas hoy
tenemos ejemplos en todo el lado de cómo
este desplazamiento podría ocurrir sólo
tenemos que ver en las fábricas en los
restaurantes
y los aeropuertos
en los bancos
pero muchas veces nos cuesta entender la
velocidad a la que estos cambios se dan
y nos cuesta creer que en realidad
podrían impactar nos a nosotros mismos
lo cierto es que para seis de cada diez
profesiones al menos un tercio de las
actividades ya son automatizables
ahora por supuesto estos avances en
tecnología traen enormes beneficios y
las mejoras en eficiencia son muy
importantes para ayudar a impulsar la
economía mundial de hecho hay varios
estudios que indican que estas
tecnologías van a creer más van a crear
más trabajos nuevos de los que van a
desplazar pero no serán el mismo tipo de
trabajos para poder seguir agregando
valor en la economía del futuro tenemos
que enfocarnos en fortalecer aquellas
capacidades que son más difíciles de
automatizar al mismo tiempo que
aprendemos a trabajar con la tecnología
y aprovecharla para fortalecer todo lo
que hacemos
el mismo estudio de mckinsey indica que
capacidades como la creatividad y la
detección de emociones son parte
fundamental de la experiencia humana y
también son difíciles de automatizar
estas son buenas noticias porque indican
que en el futuro podríamos tener una
mayor cantidad de trabajo significativo
donde la automatización se encarga de
las tareas más repetitivas más
rutinarias y nos permite enfocarnos a
nosotros en las tareas que requieren de
la creatividad y de las emociones un
asesor financiero entonces podría pasar
menos tiempo analizando datos y haciendo
cálculos y más tiempo entendiendo las
necesidades de sus clientes y
explicándoles opciones creativas
la mala noticia es que actualmente en
nuestro sistema de educación formal nos
enfocamos mucho más en desarrollar las
habilidades lógicas y analíticas en
general tenemos muy poca práctica
utilizando nuestra creatividad
en los eeuu solamente el 4% de las
actividades laborales requieren de la
creatividad a un nivel medio de
desempeño
sólo tenemos que ver a un bebé que aún
vive en un mundo nuevo y desconocido que
todo lo aprende por prueba y error para
entender que todos hemos nacido con una
enorme capacidad y lógica creativa pero
en la escuela nos han enseñado a buscar
la respuesta correcta y esa necesidad
constante de evaluar nos ha inhibido
nuestra naturaleza creativa
en costa rica tenemos un obstáculo
adicional que interfiere con la
creatividad que es la penalización del
fracaso y el miedo al fracaso que la
acompaña el miedo al fracaso es el
culpable principal de frenar la
creatividad y la innovación eso es un
problema porque por definición la
creatividad y la innovación están atadas
a situaciones ambiguas con resultados
desconocidos que dependen de la
experimentación y de la prueba y error
para evolucionar estos errores o
fracasos son la fuente principal de
aprendizaje y de ahí la frase del
fundador de onda el éxito es 99% fracaso
en nuestro país no reconocemos al
fracaso como una fuente de aprendizaje y
más bien lo vemos como algo evitar a
todo costo solo tenemos que ver las
noticias son estos empleados públicos
para identificar que como sociedad somos
más tolerantes a los que no hacen nada
recuerdan abel pacheco que los que hacen
y cometen errores
somos una cultura que en general es
adversa al riesgo en términos utilizados
por la psicología intercultural somos un
país se califica alto en la dimensión
cultural evasión de la incertidumbre
sacando 86 puntos de 100 comparado a 46
puntos en los eeuu y ocho puntos en
singapur esto se refleja en ciudadanos
que en general son resistentes al cambio
que prefieren la estructura y las reglas
y que tratan al máximo de controlar el
futuro o las situaciones ambiguas
nuestra preferencia por la estabilidad
es tan alta que un encuestó de nuestros
jóvenes de secundaria indicó que más del
70% de ellos aspira a trabajar en el
sector público donde espera tener
mejores condiciones o tal vez hasta
trabajos que puedan cumplir por el resto
de la vida
sobra decir que elevación de la
incertidumbre y elevación del riesgo y
el fracaso no son compatibles con la
creatividad y con la innovación
pero bueno qué hacemos con esto dónde
está el botón que me apretó para
encender mi creatividad y qué pasa si el
programa que tenía instalado cuando era
niña ya se me ha borrado
hoy quiero presentarles un abordaje que
promueve la creatividad y que 100%
enseñable y aprendible se trata del
pensamiento y la acción emprendedora
pero yo no hablo de la habilidad de
crear una empresa nueva yo hablo de
pensamientos y acciones que ayudan a
abrazar nos ayudan a abrazar la
incertidumbre en vez de evitarla que nos
ayudan a
buscar acciones inteligentes sobre el
planeamiento no podemos seguir planeando
a 2030 años plazo que enfatizan pasar
rápidamente de la pizarra al mundo real
es una nueva manera de ver la vida y una
nueva manera de abordar los problemas y
la incertidumbre
la universidad de babson líder mundial
en temas de emprendimiento ha
identificado seis elementos
fundamentales para poner en práctica el
pensamiento y la acción emprendedora y
aquí tomen nota porque esto es lo que
pueden enseñar a sus hijos en la casa lo
que debemos enseñarles en las escuelas y
lo que podemos aplicar en nosotros
mismos si queremos innovar
primero
tener deseo cualquier acción
emprendedora nace de un deseo de crear
algo y ver que una idea se vuelva
realidad
segundo comience con los medios a su
alcance aquí lo importante es empezar
con lo que uno tiene no con lo que uno
cree que va a necesitar
tercero pague solo lo que está dispuesto
a perder en términos de tiempo de plata
reputación hasta costo de oportunidad si
uno sabe lo que está dispuesto a perder
y sus acciones no sobrepasan esto
elimina el riesgo y retoma el control
cuarto inscriba a otros en el viaje la
colaboración y la co-creación son
esenciales para este abordaje y el
compartir con otros ayuda a validar en
nuestras ideas y aumenta nuestra base de
recursos y las posibilidades que tenemos
a nuestro alcance
5 tome pequeñas acciones en voy a
analizar todo hasta la muerte o de
desarrollar un plan estratégico perfecto
tomé una pequeña acción para empezar
y sexto reflexione y construya sobre lo
que aprende cada acción aporta un
aprendizaje que suma a todo el proceso y
aquí lo importante es celebrar cada uno
de estos aprendizajes aún cuando estén
disfrazados de fracasos
estos pasos se repiten una y otra vez y
son escalables esta es la manera de
abrazar la incertidumbre controlarla y
utilizarla para crear lo que otros no
han podido
esta metodología desarrollada en babson
ha sido tomada por el colegio lincoln
para fortalecer el pensamiento y la
acción emprendedora en sus estudiantes
han capacitado ya al cien por ciento de
sus profesores para aplicarlo en todos
los grados desde prekinder hasta 12º y
en todas las áreas de la educación tanto
dentro de las aulas como en los deportes
en las artes hasta las actividades
extracurriculares están promoviendo un
emprendimiento de todo tipo que
representa un nuevo abordaje a la
educación en el colegio y hay grandes
ejemplos de lo que los estudiantes
podrán utilizando esta metodología
los estudiantes por ejemplo se
preocuparon de que en las escuelas en
los hoteles en los restaurantes en
realidad en todo el lado se bota comida
en perfectas condiciones cuando hay
personas con hambre en costa rica
se dieron cuenta que uno de los
problemas principales es que nuestras
leyes actuales dejan a estas
organizaciones expuestas a demandas si
fueran a donar la comida y ésta tuviera
algún problema en su punto final de
consumo
buscaron ayuda tomaron pequeñas acciones
emprendieron hasta presentar un nuevo
proyecto de ley en la asamblea
legislativa que le permita a estas
organizaciones donar en la comida
aportando al bien social sin miedo a
demandas o represalias
y muchos otros ejemplos en costa rica de
cómo esto puede funcionar les mencionó
solamente uno más que es el trabajo que
yo emprendedor y otros están haciendo
junto al ministerio de educación pública
para desplegar un currículum de
emprendimiento en las 130 escuelas
rurales de costa rica
estos ejemplos deben escalar sé a todas
las escuelas de nuestro país para que
todos los niños tengan la oportunidad de
aprender
a colaborar con otros para desplegar su
creatividad a tomar pequeñas acciones
para que sus ideas se puedan convertir
en realidad y a fracasar a aprender y
perseverar
aquí quiero agregar un tema adicional
que es muy importante siempre que
hablamos del emprendimiento de la
innovación del futuro del trabajo
también hablamos sobre la ciencia de la
tecnología de ingeniería y las
matemáticas stem por sus siglas en
inglés
esto es así porque estas materias son el
fundamento de mucha de la innovación y
son importantes para que una idea se
vuelva algo concreto y algo real pero
aquí lo que es crítico es entender que
lo importante no es graduar a más y más
ingeniero científico de la computación y
nanotecnólogos
lo que es importante es acercar a estas
materias a todas las carreras
nuestros criminólogos deben saber sobre
seguridad cibernética nuestros agrónomos
deben saber manejar drones
juntos el conocimiento de estas materias
con la experiencia en el pensamiento y
la acción emprendedora permitirán que
estos jóvenes aprovechen la tecnología y
que la apliquen de manera creativa a sus
áreas de expertise y a cualquier
problema que quieran solucionar
los retos a que de ahora en adelante
apliquen los siguientes están listos
enseñen a los niños ya los jóvenes
que el fracaso es un componente crítico
del éxito y no tengan miedo cuando
cometen errores
la próxima vez que organicen un evento
en la oficina pidan que en la ronda de
introducciones todos compartan su mayor
fracaso y aprendizaje
apoyen a sus colaboradores si les dicen
que tienen una idea con la que quieren
experimentar
y sobre todo apropiamos todos de la
frase falla a menudo para que puedas
tener éxito más pronto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]